all right chris is in Wisconsin hi Chris
welcome to Dave Ramsey show I Dave
thanks so much for having me on and
thanks in advance for changing our lives
sure way to go man how can I help
so my wife and I are beginning baby step
number two tomorrow we've recently been
with an assistance program through
church that was helping us out and we
can be a lot more aggressive with our
snowball out of in our own control
versus through them wow we have about
thirty six thousand dollars in debt to
of two car loans 114 115 one of which
were upside down in in about seven
thousand and medical and consumer debt I
have about fifteen thousand in assets
that we are currently trying to sell and
I was looking to buy a beater because my
everyday drivers bought the wrong
hundred thousand miles and start
depreciating greatly so I'm concerned of
going further upside down on that car
I'm wondering hey should i buy the
feeder and be we have money in the bank
and should we use that and pay down some
of these debts yes yes and even other so
what price range or beater are you
talking about be about a four thousand
dollar car okay so let's say you got ten
left because you need a thousand and
baby step one and the which car is
upside down the most my everyday driver
which is the Honda okay and it's worth
us worth what and you know what it's
worth about fourteen on the top end and
I owe 15 okay the only thousand in the
home correct okay so you use a thousand
of your remaining ten thousand and sell
that car and it's gone right that got
rid of fourteen thousand of the
thirty-six thousand right correct that's
great what's your household income about
65 a year okay no cool so then we got
Mama's car in the end the and the
medical debts clear and you'll be okay
right
that would be it your game on man do it
definitely do it cuz you got rid of the
car payment and you got rid of almost
half your debt this is brilliant
oh and there's $10,000 to throw so the
medical debts gone too yes we would be
able to
eliminate the medical yeah I'll get his
Palmas card and you make it 65 you got
no debt man you're gonna feel like you
don't like a car out just no time well
you know this is the plan Ron where we
fall into an issue is my company was
just sold in a major acquisition so in
about five months my job becomes
redundant so I may catch a decent
severance or I may just end up on my
buck but here we won't stay you won't be
staying if the odds are against it like
I say I'm in a corporate regional
position they already have one of me at
the other company I become redundant and
so they're not gonna move you're gonna
start a company and keep you more likely
than not they may offer me something
that's within 50 miles my territory
which is anywhere from Wisconsin to
Missouri and our family's really not in
a position to pack up and move to
southern Missouri right now okay I got
you on that so what do you make
I bring home 65 oh you're buying a
single income okay all right yes sir
single income my wife is raising our two
beautiful daughters okay um well with
what we're talking about you'll be
debt-free other than her car and you'll
be beating on her car now watch what's
happening with the company and if the
storm clouds get darker and darker don't
wait on the storm to get there stop
you're Total Money Makeover and pile up
cash if the storm clouds get darker for
right now they're kind of it's off in
the distance rumbling right bet I'd like
to get her car paid off and build up a
nice war chest before all this comes
that could happen absolutely it could
okay and or you could take it an
uncomfortable position for six months
with them and then move on you know that
kind of air you like that cutting
through and so there's a lot of things
you can do to continue to eat and not
have to panic about losing your job and
because at the point that you are like a
hundred percent having an oh crap moment
not just worrying about it but this is
really coming down
you need to have stopped your
that snowball prior to that and piled up
as much cash as you can pile up to
create your own margin your own warchest
between you and and life okay okay but I
think today it sounds like it's
premature to do that okay you know it's
kind of its kind of pulling up the light
the thing on the weather channel in the
lightning strike is 22 miles away well
I'm not worried about that lightning
strike is two miles away well I think
we'll go inside fair enough you know you
know that kind of it's that kind of
thing that's what I'm talking about so
just you know let's not overreact but
let's not under react on the other side
later I'm hoping hopeful that you can
with your newfound zeal really crank on
this budget worked extra jobs sell more
stuff have garage sales and let's get
her car paid off ASAP and start building
your own war chest so you never have to
slow down because your next step once
her car's gone to build the emergency
fund anyway but at the point that you
you know if you haven't gotten there
then stop and build build a rainy day
fund if you can see the ring really
coming across the horizon and so it's
there so you never know though they may
offer you a severance of to two years of
income you never know what happens
people do all kinds of things and so or
you know you just get into all kinds of
weird things it's possible everything's
possible what's interesting I remember
reading Dale Carnegie when I was
eighteen years old how to win friends
and influence people and one things he
talks about and some of his writings I
don't remember was in that book or in
something else of his I read but
he said how to deal with worry we all
worry about things from Tonto how do you
deal with worry the first step of
dealing with worry is figuring out that
about 80% of what we worry about never
happens that helps and another portion
of what you worry about there's nothing
you can do about it and so don't spend
any time worrying about things that
aren't going to occur and things you
have no control over that gets rid of a
lot of worries right there